you know anytime you do a rematch you're
going to get asked the same question and
the answer doesn't overly matter you
just have to have an answer but what's
going to be different this time and that
is where it gets complicated I mean they
fought that fight where is he wanted to
fight it there's not going to be a
make-believe interview that Izzy comes
out and says well I knew I should have
taken him down I know I should have
pinned him up against the fence and drop
my elbows like that's where I think that
it gets a little bit tough as a selling
feature nothing went wrong in that fight
Everything went perfect and for whatever
reason Sean Strickland was better at it
than Izzy was and and I do feel like
imagine that Izzy does say and he goes
oh no nothing's going to change I'm
going to do the same thing I'm just
gonna do it better you go you know it's
kind of a weird one because Brandon the
only reason it gets weird what happens
if Izzy comes back and beats him which
right now he's the favorite what if he
beats him something tells me we don't go
to the trilogy something tells me if we
get the belt back around Izzy we don't
extend the same favorite as Sean that
Sean's gonna have to show Tata Sonia